carlos ya tenía 198 canicas en su
colección luego compró otras 44 canicas
un año después decide que no jugarán más
a las canicas y decide dividir las de la
manera más equitativa entre los otros 31
estudiantes de su clase de matemáticas
aproximadamente cuántas canicas recibirá
cada uno de sus compañeros y esto es
importante estamos hablando de
aproximadamente es decir no vamos a
buscar el número exacto simplemente un
número que se acerque de tal manera que
tengamos una división lo más equitativa
posible vámonos con los datos
principales tenemos que carlos ya tenía
198 canicas vamos a poner 198 canicas
que aproximadamente esto significa este
símbolo que no es precisamente el de
igual sino que tiene estas pequeñas
ondas y nos dice que aproximadamente
equivale a un número que redondear hemos
en este caso nos vamos al lugar de las
unidades y tenemos 18 si este número de
las unidades fuese 5 o más grande
entonces redondear hemos hacia la decena
de arriba si fuese un 4 o un 3 un 2 o un
1 pues redondear y amos hacia la decena
de abajo en este caso tenemos 198 por lo
que redondear hemos este 8 hacia arriba
digamos que haremos un aproximado de 200
canicas ok
estas 200 canicas son como el número
total de canicas que tendría previo a la
compra de otras 44 así es que sumaremos
44 canicas las cuales también redondear
emos
justo aquí está el caso que les decía
vemos la parte de las unidades dado que
redondear hemos a la decena más cercana
y este es un 4 por lo que redondear
hemos hacia abajo es decir de 44 canicas
nos iremos solo a 40
y de esta manera haremos la suma de
ambos números tenemos 200 técnicas
previas aproximadamente y otras 40
canicas que compro más tarde tendremos
entonces un total de 240 canicas
recuerda de todo esto será un aproximado
entonces nos dice que al final de un año
decide dividirlas de la manera más
equitativa entre treinta y uno de sus
compañeros 31 compañeros recuerda que
éste también lo aproximaremos y lo
redondeamos hacia la decena más cercana
tenemos en el lugar de las unidades un 1
por lo que redondear hemos hacia abajo y
tendremos entonces un aproximado de 30
compañeros en su clase de matemáticas
si nosotros hacemos la división
correspondiente para resolver la
pregunta cuántas canicas recibirá cada
uno podemos decir que tendremos 240
canicas
las cuales serán divididas
entre 30
y con eso tendremos voy a colocar una
serie de canicas y tendremos sé que será
la cantidad de canicas que recibirá cada
uno de sus compañeros o también podemos
verlo de la siguiente manera podemos
decir que 240 que es el total de las
canicas aproximadamente será igual
hacen que es el total de canicas que
recibirá cada uno de sus compañeros
por 30
vamos bien esta es la manera en la que
nosotros podemos decir que hay un número
incógnito el cual si multiplicamos por
30 nos dará 240 tenemos datos
importantes y con eso podemos sacar esta
respuesta
veamos si nosotros buscamos dentro de
los múltiplos de 30 tal vez encontremos
la respuesta y buscaremos entonces 30
por 1 es igual a 30 por 2 es igual a 60
por 3 es igual a 90 se fijan es muy muy
muy parecido a la tabla de multiplicar
del 3 simplemente que aquí tenemos un
cero añadido en el lugar de las unidades
y el múltiplo de 3 está en la posición
de las decenas entonces avanzaríamos 3
por 30 por 39 30 por 4 120
y 240 esto significa que multiplicamos
30 por 1 2 3 4 5 6
78 30 por 8 es igual a 240
que lo tenemos aquí así es que podemos
resolver que nuestro resultado será
treinta por ocho a cada uno de sus
compañeros le corresponderá
aproximadamente ocho canicas sé que
habíamos quedado que es el número
aproximado de canicas que recibirá cada
uno será entonces
y de hecho si nosotros hiciéramos la
suma de estos números sin aproximar no
tendríamos entonces un número así 84 12
llevamos 19 más 1 10 más 4 14 llevamos 1
uno más uno es igual a 2 242 comparado
con 240 es decir tuvimos un acercamiento
bastante bastante bueno y si nosotros
dividiremos 242 entre 31 bueno
posiblemente nos daría un dolor de
cabeza simplemente lo que quiero que
vean es que esto de las aproximaciones
nos daría un 88 por 30 nos dará 240 de
hecho si se dan cuenta podemos tener que
8 por 3 es igual a 24 de la misma manera
de la misma manera que 8 por 30 será
igual a 240 aquí tenemos un aumento a la
categoría de decenas es por ello que en
nuestro resultado se va a las centenas
simplemente era para que vieran la
similitud con la tabla de multiplicar
del 3 y del 30 para cerrar este vídeo
simplemente contestaremos cuántas
canicas recibirá cada uno de sus
compañeros aproximadamente pues
aproximadamente recibirá cada 18 canicas
y esa es nuestra respuesta